[Musik]
herzlich willkommen in meiner taten
weltweite gibt ein tolles trocken
tutorial ich habe in den letzten tagen
nämlich drei motiv torten gebacken
eine torte eine hochzeitstorte und eine
verlobungs torte und möchte ich jetzt
die videos jeweils sonntags hochladen
und möchte heute mit der hauptorte
starten
ich habe das video jetzt in zwei teile
gesplittet und zwar zeige ich in diesem
video hier jetzt wie man die torte macht
also was ich als füllung genommen habe
welchen teilgenommen haben immer die
torten zusammensetzt und so weiter wie
ich allerdings die figur oben drauf also
den elefanten gemacht habe zeige ich
euch einfach in einem anderen kleinen
video
damit dieses video hier nicht so lange
wird wenn ich eine torte backen dann
plane ich das ganze natürlich vorher
immer wenn ich zum beispiel weiß dass am
samstag die torte fertig sein muss dann
fange ich schon mindestens eine woche
früher haben zum beispiel habe ich jetzt
bei dieser torte bereits meine
elefantenfriedhof fertig gemacht ich
habe auch die kleinen öffentlich gemacht
wo der name drauf stand und so kann ich
mir das alles am einteilen jetzt im
video wenn ich euch das ist jetzt
natürlich so zeigen wie es logisch
klingt aber ich sage euch einfach an
geeigneter stelle was ich zum beispiel
schon vorbereitet habe und werde ich
einmal auf meinem blog auch den zeitplan
aufschreiben wie ich das ganze gebacken
haben denn es ist wirklich sehr
schwierig wenn ihr zum beispiel am
samstag die tore eben präsentieren wollt
dann am freitag anzufangen also da kommt
total im stress und man kann sich
einfach viel stress ersparen wenn man
das ganze durch organisiert
und so könnt ihr zum beispiel statt
alles an einem tag zu machen einfach
jeden tag etwas machen zum beispiel die
böden backen und abkühlen lassen
die müssen ja sowieso dann ein bisschen
ruhe damit was sie besser verarbeiten
kann und so werde ich euch das jetzt in
dem video zeigen
ich starte jetzt mit der vorbereitung
meines backblech und zwar nehme ich
meine 2pac ringe und werde in 220 cm
bringen backen
damit der teig keine kuppel bildet und
der teig ebenmäßig packt werde ich jetzt
die back rahmen mit backpapier
einschlagen und dazu messe ich jetzt
erstmal meinen umfang aus und schneidet
das backpapier zurecht das backpapier
fall ich dann in der mitte und halbiere
es so dass ich zwei gleich dicke
streifen habe und dann faltig unten etwa
einen drei zentimeter hohen rand und
werde das backpapier dort dann
einschneiden einfach damit ich es gleich
dann um die back entwickeln kann
jetzt da ich nicht mehr hier noch den
kreis vor und schneide ihn mit einer
schere aus und besprühen programme mit
etwas back trance prey könnte auch
einfach mit etwas butter einstreichen
und dann das backpapier hineinlegen
das hilft einfach dabei das backpapier
schon im kleben bleibt und eben am rand
bleibt in nicht ständig wieder weggeht
[Musik]
aber wenn auch der boden eingesetzt
jetzt möchte ich das meinen teig
gleichmäßig backt und deswegen werde ich
heute isoliert backen
das heißt ich muss jetzt etwas
küchenrolle ab und macht diesen us
entwickler sie dann alufolie das hilft
einfach dass der teig gleichmäßiger hoch
backt und eben keine kuppel bildet
das küchenpapier wirklich dann in die
alufolie 1
entwickle dann diesen alufolien streifen
um einen bug rahmen herum und befestigt
gehen einfach indem ich das ganze
drumherum zwirbler unten kommt jetzt
auch noch eine schicht alufolie damit
auch unten natürlich gleichmäßig packt
und dann habt ihr schon die
vorbereitungen für den tag getroffen an
zutaten brauchen wir acht eier in größe
m 320 gramm butter oder margarine 250
190 km
ich habe zwar bitterschokolade ihr könnt
aber auch zum beispiel 70
vollmilchschokolade würde ich nicht
neben was dann wirklich süß und zu wenig
schokolade mit 30 gramm probe fordern
die gute bank ag und sein und einen
kollektiven backpulver das ist ein halt
zuerst gebe ich jetzt die butter in
einem topf und stark kommt auch die
schokolade mit dazu
das ganze wird dann mal mittlerer stufe
erhitzt so dass sich die schokolade
auflöst dann kommt da noch der zucker
mit dazu und ich verrührt das ganze und
und schalt den härter noch aus und lasst
das ganze etwa zehn minuten abkühlen die
eier gebe ich dann in eine glasschüssel
und verrühren sie und gäbe dann die
abgekühlte schokolade mit hinein und
daher ist auch wichtig dass die
schokolade abgekühlt ist ansonsten
entsteht hier nämlich dann rührei und
ihr seht auch bei diesem rezept brauche
ich da keine küchenmaschine ich liebe
dann die trockenen zutaten wie mehl
backpulver und kakaopulver hinein und
verrührt es dann mit dem schneebesen
dieser teig kommt dann in meine
vorbereiteten zwei backformen und ich
backe in zwei backformen damit der teig
einfach nicht zu viel ist und eben höher
aufgeht
das ganze wird dann bei etwa 165 grad
für ungefähr 35 minuten gebacken macht
auf jeden fall die stäbchen probe und
lasst den kuchen dann zwei stunden
abkühlen
danach entferne ich den tortenring und
das backpapier entwickelt den teig in
frischhaltefolie ein und gebe ihnen dann
für einen tag in den kühlschrank für die
frucht sind brauchen wir 600 tonnen
früchte ich habe jetzt einfach wer sich
hier und rahmen genommen aber da könnt
ihr einfach jede frucht nehmen ihr euch
schmeckt da gehen auch die küste aber
ich bin total nach frischen früchten ich
habe jetzt einfach die 40 grad saison
haben und bananen bald sehr gute
schokolade passt hier habe ich nur noch
wenige liter wasser da kann man auch
ganz gut sagt nehmen oder zb auch in de
coeur
falls ihr das gerne möchte hier habe ich
100 gramm zucker und zwei tüten alpine
das entspricht 12 bleibt
als ihr könnt entweder aktive regelt
dass hier die pflanzliche variante im
rein französischen mitte und eine
gardine entspricht 6 klatsche maschine
das heißt ihr könnt auch wurfmaschine
oder 2
die früchte gebe ich dann in einen mixer
und püriert sie durch das geht natürlich
auch mit einem stabmixer und gebe sie
dann in einen kleinen topf geben
eventuell sogar mit dazu bei mir waren
jetzt aber die früchte süß genug
deswegen habe ich jetzt keinen zucker
dazu gegeben weil säuerlichen früchten
würde ich aber etwas zucker hinzufügen
und gäbe dann das wasser und die
akademie mit rein und früher das schön
mit einem schneebesen anschließend wird
dieses fruchtpüree solange gerührt bis
es aufgekocht ist und dann muss es
gemeinsam mit der agile mindestens zwei
minuten lang gerührt werden und gekocht
werden damit die akademie ihre wirkung
entfalten kann
ich werde mein fruchtpüree jetzt wieder
in einen bug rahmen gießen und
verschließt diesen deswegen mit etwas
frischhaltefolie und nehme hier bei 2
back rahmen einmal einen großen und
einen kleinen als der zweistöckige torte
wird
und hierbei müsst ihr einfach beachten
dass der rahmen etwa 2 cm kleiner ist im
durchmesser als euro
das ganze lasse ich dann bei
zimmertemperatur fest werden und löse
dann den bug rahmen
ich werde dann das fertige fertig
sanierte fruchtpüree in frischhaltefolie
ein und frisst dann ein damit es etwas
stabiler ist und ich es besser halten
kann ihr seht nämlich ist es ziemlich
weich und so könnte ich es zum beispiel
nicht auf die torte legen weil es
einfach zu unhandlich ist am nächsten
tag halbiere ich dann meine kuchen ich
habe insgesamt zwei stück gebacken und
hab dann nach dem schneiden vier helfen
auf eine körper platte die ich jetzt
entsprechend zugeschnitten habe streiche
ich etwas zarter kanals und lege meinen
tortenboden drauf das rezept für die
zeit bitter ghana steht auf meinem blog
den ersten boten bedenke ich jetzt mit
etwas gar lasch und für streich ist mit
meiner winkel palette darauf gebe ich
jetzt das gefrorene fruchtpüree und
wundert euch nicht dass es jetzt
aussieht also wer die frischhaltefolie
drauf die habe ich natürlich vorher
entfernt ich denke es dann noch mal mit
einer schicht kann ab und gebt den
zweiten boden drauf und jetzt kommt
immer mal wieder garage und dann der
nächste boden und hier achte ich einfach
drauf dass ich mit einem ganz glatten
boden abschließe so dass der kuchen
richtig schön gerade wird
jetzt kontrolliere ich noch dass sie
richtig übereinander sitzt und mein
kuchen war jetzt etwa 11 cm hoch
anschließend denke ich ihn mit einer
cover platte ab die ich vorher mit
frischhaltefolie eingedeckt habe und
jetzt könnt ihr auch sehen die ränder
sind ungleichmäßig und diese offenen
rentiert mit garage gefühl in kuchen
hatte er vorher jetzt etwa eine halbe
stunde im kühlschrank
jetzt habe ich etwas ganz auf den deckel
der torte gegeben und die platte wieder
drauf gesetzt und jetzt gebe ich immer
mal wieder zimmer war mit garage auf den
kuchen und siehst dann mit einer
tankkarte ab und gebt den kuchen immer
wieder für fünf minuten in den
kühlschrank damit die gerne rasch west
werden können und bereit ist für die
nächste schicht ihr könnt zum abziehen
aber auch ein lineal benutzen ich habe
ihm ein lineal in meiner küche und gebt
dann die garage mieter mit einer winde
palette drauf und du siehst dann ab
wenn der rand schön glatt ist kümmert
ihr euch um die oberfläche der torte und
gibt da auch noch mal etwas ganz drauf
und verscharrt genauso wie am rand also
immer wieder gerne wieder abziehen und
das ganze eben im wechsel bis die torte
zum schluss komplett glatt ist und
bereit für den verband ist
[Musik]
jetzt müsst ihr noch kontrollieren ob
die torte gleichmäßig hoch ist damit sie
nicht schief wird das mache ich einmal
mit einem jahr und einmal mit einer
kleinen wasserwaage und wenn ihr
komplett zufrieden seid darf die torte
einfach in den kühlschrank
sie kümmere ich mich jetzt um eine deko
steine und zwar verwende ich jetzt
blüten passte die ich übrigens
mittlerweile auch fertig kaufen
die gibt es auch in meinem shop und ich
verlinke sie euch einfach in der infobox
ich habe jetzt die blüten passte einmal
in hellem türkis und aber in türkis
eingefärbt und möchte daraus jetzt die
kleinen steinchen machen auf die ich
dann die namen schreibe zum ausholen
benutze ich immer etwas becker stärke
und zum glattstreichen benutze ich jetzt
einfach frei
hofer als 23 klettern nehmen als
abstandhalter auf plätzchen jetzt
schneide ich die würfel etwa 2 x 2 cm
groß
und rolle dann etwas weiße blüten passte
ganz dünn aus und schneidet diese etwas
kleiner als 2 x 2 cm zurecht
anschließend nehme ich etwas rote farbe
ich habe ich jetzt wieder die farbe aus
der tube und rolle die blüten passte ich
hier auch ganz schön aus und werde mit
meinen buchstaben ausstechen
die buchstaben ausstechen und hier
empfiehlt es sich mit einem modell
werkzeug zu arbeiten
anschließend gebe ich die weißen
kästchen auf die blauen würfel drauf und
klebe dann mit etwas zucker kleber die
buchstaben traum
eventuell müssen sie noch angepasst
werden und können dann auch mit etwas
cnc kleber angeklebt werden
jetzt kümmere ich mich um das eindecken
der torte und nehme dazu etwas rolf an
land gebe etwas palmen auf meine hände
damit nicht an meinen händen klebt und
färbe meinen rolf und dann mit etwas
farbe
das ganze wird dann mit becker stärke
schön rund ausgerollt und da empfiehlt
es sich einfach einen aus wohl stab aus
silikon zu nehmen damit nix anklebt und
dieser ist eben auch schön lang und
dadurch dass sie denn fondant immer
wieder dreht bitte auch schön rund
[Musik]
dann könnt ihr den ausgerückten fondant
auf den ausruf starb aufrollen und dann
über die torte wieder ausrollen
nehmt euch da auf jeden fall genug zeit
und streicht die torte dann mit dem auto
und starb etwas klatsch der überschuss
wird dann entfernt
und jetzt arbeitet ihr von oben nach
unten am rand entlang und sie denn von
dann immer wieder zur seite weg und
streicht ihn weiter glatt so verhindert
er dass der von land reist und dass er
an den rändern schön faltenfrei wird
den überschuss nehme ich dann mit einem
teig rädchen weg
[Musik]
und glatter meine torte mit meinen opern
und benutze dann auch meine kleine
winkel palette um die letzten überreste
wegzunehmen und den letzten schliff gebe
ich die torte mit einer schaumstoff
platte in dem ich so dann auch die
bäcker stärke entfernt
anschließend gebe ich meine torte auf
eine tortenplatte auf dich etwas gas
gegeben habe und jetzt möchte ich den
rand der torte mit streifen dekorieren
und benutze zur hilfe etwas wachs
papieren diesen vorgang müsst ihr nicht
machen
ihr könnt auch etwas backpapier nehmen
aber wachs papier klebt eben viel besser
aus weißem sondern schneide ich mir
jetzt 15 cm breite streifen zu recht
[Musik]
gebe diese auf meinen wachs papier und
krebse da eben schön drauf eine kante
schneidig ab damit sie unten an der
torte schön anlegt und bestreichen dann
die weißen streifen mit etwas zucker
kleber jetzt kann ich so den kompletten
streifen einfach um die torte herum
legen und damit einfacher ist halte ich
mir vorher immer mein wachs papier
metern zufrieden seid könnt ihr zitate
stapeln und um sie zu stapeln müsst ihr
ein paar holzstöcke hineinstecken damit
die obere torte nicht in die untere
pforte ein sagt und wenn ihr diese
abgemessen habt und reingesteckt habt
kann die zweite torte obendrauf gesetzt
werden
die tortenplatte decke ich mit etwas
blüten passte ab die ich jetzt rot
eingefärbt habe man kann natürlich auch
die komplette tortenplatte vorher
eindecken
aber ich finde es immer ein bisschen
unnötig und hab das jetzt einfach
hinterher immer das ganze dann schön
ausgeholt und am rand sauber
abgeschnitten
die tortenplatte habe ich dann mit etwas
zucker kleber eingepinselt und konnte
dann den roten zucker rand außen herum
liegen
[Musik]
das ganze habe ich dann mit einem
klettergurt gestrichen und die überreste
mit einem marzipan messer abgenommen um
einen schönen effekt zu bekommen könnt
ihr zum beispiel einen zahnstocher
nehmen oder einen schaschlikspieß und
die platte noch etwas motivieren
hier habe ich noch einen kleinen teppich
geformt für meine figur und habe diese
schöne ausgestochen und mit etwas zucker
kleber drauf geklebt
die zucker figur habe ich einfach drauf
gesetzt und mit etwas vor leißing
festgeklebt
[Musik]
für die obere etage habe ich mir gedacht
dass ich ein paar kreise ausstechen und
diese dann auf die torte klebe
und die kleinen steinchen habe ich an
der torte angeordnet und sie danach
etwas abgestaubt und mit back trend
spray eingesprüht damit sie etwas
glänzen und sie dann der reihe nach mit
zucker thema aufgeklebt der elefant hat
den letzten schliff bekommen durch eine
lieferung den ich auf einen draht
aufgespießt habe und dadurch dass man
den grad erhitzt kann man ihnen einfach
ganz leicht in den rüssel hinein stecken
und der bleibt dann schön in der luft
hängen und so sah dann zum schluss die
fertige torte
insgesamt habe ich wahrscheinlich so um
die 15 bis 20 stunden zeit auch von
hineingesteckt also von der elefanten
figur über die kleine würfelchen mit dem
name drauf bis hin zum fertigen torte
und natürlich fragt ihr euch
wahrscheinlich was hat die torte
gekostet oder hast du sie verkauft also
ich mache gar keine torten aufträge auf
bestellung weiß ich dass ein für mich
nicht lohnt weder zeitlich noch
finanziell
man müsste für so eine torte wirklich
viel geld verlangen weil ihr nicht nur
die das arbeitsmaterial drin steckt also
die zutaten man benutzt sein werkzeug
man muss backpapier alufolie verbrauchen
wir verbrauchen natürlich auch strom
wasser und das sind natürlich viele
sachen und dann habt ihr euch immer noch
nicht selber euren lohn praktisch
gegeben und ihr müsst euch doch selber
würdigen wenn ihr torten für andere
packt was ihr dafür verlangt also das
was ihr natürlich verdienen würde das
kann keiner bezahlen weil das ist eine
handarbeit und man steckt einfach viel
arbeit und viel liebe auch hinein
deswegen mag ich für freunde eigentlich
nur auch nur in ausnahmefällen weil ich
einfach die zeit auch nicht mehr dazu
haben ich mache es natürlich zum
beispiel um neue techniken mal
auszuprobieren oder einfach zb um ein
video zu drehen und euch zu zeigen wie
ich das mache ich würde mich natürlich
freuen wenn er zum beispiel auch mal ein
paar fotos von tautropfen schicken könnt
ob wir das auch schon mal gemacht habt
oder eine kleine elefanten figur und ich
hoffe dass ich so ein bisschen
anregungen geben konnte und dass ich das
wieder gefallen hat ich werde das in
zukunft auch ein paar basic videos
machen wie ich es ja schon länger vor
hatte also ein paar tropfen basics und
wird einfach jeweils kurze videos dazu
machen
ich wünsche euch noch ganz viel spaß
beim schauen hab da schon geschaut aber
ich wünsche euch einen ganz schönen tag
und das rezept gibt es dann wie immer
orton wéinst de buchbar